hello i'm sami zayd and this is the
newshour live from doha
it's 1500 gmt that's 10 a.m
in washington dc we're bringing you
special extended coverage of the fifth
day of donald trump's impeachment trial
in the u.s senate
as it approaches its conclusion well
senators are reconvening soon
we'll find out if we're heading to a
final vote on the charges that
trump incited an insurrection at capitol
hill on january the 6th
the senate needs a two-thirds majority
to convict him
on friday trump's lawyers wrapped up his
defense
taking less than four of the 16 hours
available to them
let's go first to alan fisher he's live
for us at capitol hill in washington dc
so alan
let's start with how things will kick
off and the big question today
is whether or not they're going to end
up calling witnesses right
there's been a huge debate overnight
among the democrats and the house
managers about whether or not they
should call witnesses key to be called
would be kevin mccarthy the leader
of the republicans in the house for the
telephone call he had with donald trump
asking him to send help
when the capital was overrun and also to
call mike pence the vice president
all about when he was at risk and when
did the president know that
and whether or not the president
expressed any concern
now the debate is they think that
senators have already made up their
minds they know the timeline they know
what happened they're well aware of all
the facts but many of them decided
they're standing by donald trump anyway
and they are going to acquit so the
question that the house managers are
juggling with
is there any value in calling witnesses
at this stage given
that the votes are probably accounted
for we know that mitch mcconnell has
in the last hour he of course is the
leader of the republicans in the senate
has said it's a close call
but he is going to vote to quit this is
a man who said this was a matter of
conscience
and many thought could be a swing vote
so if he is going to vote for a quit
it seems unlikely that the democrats are
going to win their case
here's another thing that's concerning
them the trump defense have said look if
you call witnesses it's going to get
messy we're going to call nancy pelosi
we'll call the mayor of washington d.c
we'll ask what they did to make the
capital secure on
january the 6th so this big debate is
still ongoing i was told just
even in the last 10 minutes they were
still talking about whether or not to
call witnesses
we'll only know if they're going to go
ahead with that when the senate
reconvenes
if they do not call witnesses and it's
two hours each for summing up
and there's every possibility we could
get a vote by the end of business
on saturday here in washington all right
alan stay with us there's tons for us to
talk about with you but let's
for now go over to andy gallacher he's
live for us in west palm beach in
florida
andy we're approaching what we think is
kind of the end of this process
depending of course on how it goes with
the whole calling of witnesses that
allen was explaining there but are we
hearing anything
from donald trump it's an eerie silence
isn't there
yeah very eerie silence particularly
when we got used to over the four years
he was
president this constant stream of
consciousness over social media of
course he's banned from
his favorite platform twitter remember
in his first
impeachment trial he tweeted 140 times
in one day i had an interesting
conversation with one of the pool
reporters
here in west palm beach who's covering
any potential press conferences by the
president
he said that he thinks the lawyers that
are working for the former president now
told him they would do so if he stayed
quiet during this entire trial now we
can't confirm that but it would explain
i think why the president has been the
former president i should say has been
uh so quiet for so long on thursday he
uh played golf
we think for sure he was watching on
friday and most likely
today for the final result of the second
impeachment
what do we all right
thanks uh alan let's go back uh thanks
andy i should say let's go back to allen
now and
take us through then you were just
getting us through the process then alan
once
they decide whether or not they're going
to actually call and i should point out
that it's patrick leahy there
who is presiding over the senate trial
so we're going to have to watch things
we may have to jump in but until we do
alan take us through what will happen
today once we get
one way or another pass this vote on on
witnesses
they may proceed well just to touch on
the the question of donald trump being
very quiet i was told that his legal
team
and others around him have said say
nothing we've got this
the result's almost certain you don't
need to do anything jamie raskin who is
leading
the uh prosecution for the democratic
house managers has taken
the platform in the senate why don't we
go into the senate and hear what he's
got to say and we'll find out whether or
not they're calling witnesses lit a
match
and then continued his incitement even
even as he failed to defend us from the
ensuing violence we've supported
our position with images videos
affidavits documents tweets and other
evidence
leaving no doubt that the senate should
convict we believe we've proven our case
but last night congresswoman jamie
herrera butler of washington state
issued a statement confirming
that in the middle of the insurrection
when house minority leader kevin
mccarthy called the president to beg for
help
president trump responded and i quote
well kevin
i guess these people are more upset
about the election
than you are needless to say
this is uh an additional
critical piece of corroborating evidence
further confirming the charges before
you
as well as the president's willful
declaration
dereliction of duty and desertion of
duty as commander-in-chief of the united
states
his state of mind and his further
incitement of the
insurrection on january 6th for that
reason and because this is the proper
time
to do so under the resolution that the
senate adopted
to set the rules for the trial we would
like the opportunity to subpoena
congresswoman
herrera regarding her communications
with house
minority leader kevin mccarthy and to
subpoena
her contemporaneous notes that she made
regarding what president
trump told kevin mccarthy in the middle
of the insurrection we would be prepared
to proceed by zoom deposition
of an hour or less just as soon as
congresswoman herrera butler
is available and to then proceed to the
next phase of the trial
including the introduction of that
testimony shortly thereafter
congresswoman butler further stated that
she hopes other witnesses
to this part of the story other patriots
that she put it
would come forward and if that happens
we would seek
the opportunity to take their
depositions via zoom
also for less than an hour or to
subpoena other relevant documents as
well
president thank you senators good
morning
and good morning to the american people
the first thing i want to say on the
issue of witnesses
is that the house manager just got up
here
and described the articles of
impeachment
and the charges there is no plural
here that's wrong there's one article
of impeachment and there's one charge
and that's incitement of violence and
insurrection
what you all need to know and the
american people need to know is
as of late yesterday afternoon there was
a stipulation going around that there
weren't going to be
any witnesses but
after what happened here in this chamber
yesterday
the house managers realized they did not
investigate this case before bringing
the impeachment they did not give the
proper
uh consideration and work they didn't
put the work in
that was necessary to impeach the former
president
but if they want to have witnesses
i'm going to need at least over a
hundred
depositions not just one
the real issue is incitement they
put into their case over a hundred
witnesses
people who have been charged with crimes
by the federal government
and each one of those they said
that mr trump was a co-conspirator
with that's not
true but i have the right to defend that
the only thing that i ask if you vote
for witnesses
do not handcuff me
by limiting the number of witnesses
that i can have i need to do
a thorough investigation that they did
not do
i need to do the 9-1-1 style
investigation that nancy pelosi called
for
it should have been done already it's a
dereliction of the house manager's duty
that they didn't and now at the last
minute after a stipulation had
apparently been worked out
they want to go back on that i think
that's inappropriate and improper
we should close this case out today
we have each prepared our closing
arguments
we each i mean i had eight days to get
ready for this thing
but we each had those eight days equally
together to prepare ourselves
and the house managers need to live with
the case that they brought
but if they don't please in
all fairness in an all due
process do not
limit my ability to discover
discover discover
the truth that would be
another sham and that's the president's
position
my position
i should just have it standing by
sisters
mr ascot
thank you mr president first of all this
is
the proper time that we were assigned to
talk about witnesses this is completely
within the course of the rules set forth
by the senate there's nothing remotely
unusual about this i think we've done an
exceedingly thorough and comprehensive
job
with all the evidence that was available
last night
this was breaking news and it responded
directly to a question that was being
raised
by the president's defense council
saying that we had not sufficiently
proven to their satisfaction although i
think we've proven the satisfaction of
the american people certainly that the
president
after the breach and the invasion took
place
was not working on the side of defending
the capital
but rather was continuing to pursue his
political goals and the information that
came out last night by
congresswoman butler apparently backed
up by contemporaneous notes
that she had taken i think will put to
rest any lingering doubts
raised by the president's council who
now says he wants to
interview hundreds of people there's
only one person the president's council
really needs to interview
and that's their own client
and bring him forward as we suggested
last week
because a lot of this is uh matters that
are in his head
why did he not act to defend the country
after he learned of the attack why was
he continuing
to press the political case but this
piece of evidence is relevant to that
and uh finally uh but i was i was
a little bit mystified by the point
about the article of impeachment
which i referred to
the dereliction of duty the desertion of
duty is built
into the incitement charge obviously
if the president of the united states is
out inciting a violent insurrection he's
obviously
not doing his job at the same time just
like
if a police officer is mugging you yeah
he's guilty of
theft and armed robbery whatever it
might be but he's also not doing his job
as a police officer
officer so it's further evidence of his
intent and what his conduct is
first of all it's my understanding it's
been reported
that mr mccarthy disclaims the rumors
that have been the basis of this
morning's antics but really the rumors
that have been the basis of this entire
proceeding this entire proceeding is
based on rumor
report innuendo there's nothing to it
and they didn't do their work
just like what happened with mr lee two
or three nights ago
some supposed conversation it happened
and they had to withdraw that they had
to back off of that because it was
false it was a false narrative
but it is one article of impeachment
yeah they threw a lot of stuff in it in
violation of rule 23.
rule 23 says you cannot combine
counts it's a defect in their entire
case
it's one of the four reasons why you can
to vote to acquit in this case
jurisdiction rule 23 due process
and the first amendment they all apply
in this case
uh let me let me let me take my own
advice and cool the temperature in the
room a little bit
it's about the incitement it's not about
what happened
afterwards that's actually the
irrelevant stuff
that's the irrelevant stuff it's not the
things that were said from the election
to january 6th
it's not relevant to the legal analysis
of the issues that are before this body
it doesn't matter what happened after
the insurgents into the capitol building
because that doesn't have to do with
incitement
incitement is it is it's it's a point in
time
folks it's a point in time when the
words are
spoken and the words say
implicitly say explicitly say
commit acts of violence or lawlessness
and we don't have that here so for
the house managers to say we need
depositions about things that happened
after
it's not just not true but
but if he does
there are a lot of depositions that need
to be happened
nancy pelosi's deposition needs to be
taken
vice president uh harris is uh
deposition
absolutely needs to be taken and not by
zoom
none of these depositions should be done
by zoom
we didn't do this hearing by zoom
these depositions should be done in
person in my office
in philadelphia that's where they should
be done
[Laughter]
i don't know how many civil lawyers are
here but that's the way it works
folks when you want somebody's
deposition
you send a notice of deposition and they
appear at the place where the notice
says that's civil process
i don't know why you're laughing it is
civil process
that is the way lawyers do it we send
notices of deposition
i would remind everybody
we will have water yeah in
the chamber if you
during these proceedings
i haven't laughed at any of you and
there's nothing laughable here
he mentioned my client coming in to
testify
that is not the way it's done if he
wanted to talk to donald trump
he should have put a subpoena down like
i'm going to slap subpoenas
on a good number of people if witnesses
are what
is required here for them to try to get
their case back in order
which is failed miserably for four
reasons
there is no jurisdiction here there has
been
no due process here they have completely
violated and ignored and stepped on
the constitution of the united states
they have trampled on it like people who
have no respect for it
and if this is about nothing else it has
to be about the respect of our country
our constitution and all of the people
that make it up
and so that i ask when considering or
voting on this
witness matter and to be clear this may
be the time to do it but again and
everybody needs to know that in the
backroom politics i'm not so much into
it all and i'm not too
adept at it neither
but there was a stipulation
they felt pretty comfortable after day
two
until their case was tested on day three
now is the time to end this now is the
time to hear the closing arguments
now is the time to vote your conscience
thank you
mr raskin
we were involved in no discussions about
a stipulation
um and i have no further comment thank
you mr president
position on that
i would remind
i would remind everybody as chief
justice roberts noted on january 21st
2020
studying the trial of carol swain 1905
all parties in this chamber must refrain
from using language
that is not conducive to civil discourse
i listened to chief justice robert say
that
i agreed with him and i thought for
our colleagues i would repeat it as i
did last night
so the question we have before us is
whether it shall be in order to consider
the debate
under the rules of impeachment any
motion to subpoena witnesses
or documents
the request for the a's and nays has
been made is there a sufficient second
there appears to be there is
the clerk will call the roll
miss baldwin